why
so as we get into our discussion about
the Four Horsemen of Apocalypse I'd like
you to keep our video about the Thanos
Thanos quest in mind and the reason why
is because if you recall our discussion
about the Thanos quest we had talked
about health a nose had undertaken the
task of getting the infinity gems but
had done it by by either coercing or
tricking people with apocalypse it's
much the same way apocalypse in terms of
him gaining his horsemen does it in a
way to where he more or less dupes
people or he preys on people who were
otherwise in a weakened state now of
course with apocalypse having first
appeared in the early issues of x-factor
he always operated with a team that is
to say there were people that carried
out his goals
now apocalypse is I guess is rationale
here was that it was a way for them to
demonstrate their strength to
demonstrate that they were stronger than
the people they were going against and
if they were unable to maintain this
role he would have them replaced to
always maintain this element that the
strong should should outlive the weak
and so with x-factor issue number 10 we
pick up in the midst of the mutant
Massacre and if you guys recall our
discussion about the x-men we had talked
about how with the mutant Massacre there
were a multitude of things that spiraled
out of this and this is one of them
during the mutant Massacre event we of
course have seen that plague was on the
verge of being killed by harpoon she of
course had already managed to subdue a
to subdue Sabretooth but during this
process apocalypse had appeared to her
in the Morlock tunnels and apocalypse
told her that he would take her to make
her the the horseman pestilence issue
was willing to if she was willing to
come along with this and of course he
had a I guess appealed to her by talking
about how she had incredible power or
that her power could be used for a
better purpose than what it was
currently being used for and with plague
as part of the Morlocks this was
something that really resonated with her
and the reason why is because the
Morlocks were what they were because
they felt like outcasts they felt like
they didn't have a place and so by
apocalypse coming to her and saying he
would make her a pestilence it gave her
a role it gave her something gave her
some kind of purpose from here we
switched to a person named Abraham and
Abraham had formerly fought another via
more but the conflict had left him
paralyzed from the neck down
and so apocalypse appeared to him in the
hospital and told him that he would give
him back his ability to walk he would
give him back his ability to use the
remaining part of his body
of course again he appeals to the to the
powers that war has by saying that his
ability to clap his hands and create a
destructive force somewhere is something
that would really resonate with the
desires that Apocalypse had and so again
preying on the I guess the vulnerable
nature of Abraham at the time apocalypse
takes Abraham and turns them into the
horsemen war from here we transition to
a girl named autumn roll of autumn
raphson and autumn raphson is a girl who
has the ability to more or less I guess
to undertake the role of Fame and her
power allows her to remove food or to
turn food into dust or to turn anything
into dust and so of course her being a
younger person is not necessarily
shunned by her parents but her parents
are extremely protective of her and so
of course her parents after seeing her
use her abilities lash out and ask her
if she really wants x-factor to come and
take her away again touching back on our
discussion of X Factor when X Factor was
operating as though they were a a mutant
gathering force they were operating to
capture mutants of course pestilence or
I guess some autumn gets very very angry
at her parents over this so the fact
that she doesn't really isn't really
allowed any measure of freedom and so
when she lashes out against her parents
she of course leaves and goes to her
room and when she does she's greeted by
apocalypse and once again capitalizing
on the vulnerable nature apocalypse says
that he can give her a place that she
can he can give her the power that she
needs to get revenge on her parents if
that's what she wants to do and so again
taking her as his third horseman he
transforms her into famine now with
angel it's a little more complicated
here angel has a more in-depth story in
terms of how it was that he had become
the horseman death and it actually
stretches over several comics with angel
we of course had seen him fighting
against the the Marauders during the
mutant Massacre event but his conflict
with the harpoon had damaged his wings
this of course was the first time we had
seen Thor appear when
Thor had found him into a wall with his
wings having been damaged but over the
course of the mutant massacre and after
the mutant massacre event was over it
got to a point where by angel's wings
had to be removed of course his wings
were effectively dying but because they
were dying
they were also contracting gangrene and
of course Jean Grey hadn't formed one
Worthington that he would lose the use
of his wings and then eventually Warren
Worthington wakes up to find his wings
were gone entirely now there were a
couple other things that take place here
we of course had seen that Cameron Hodge
had tried to kill a Warren Worthington
on several occasions but eventually
Warren Worthington wakes up in the
celestial spaceship of apocalypse an
apocalypse says that he can give him
back his ability to use his wings he can
give him back what it is that he desires
most but only if he undertakes the
mantle of being being the horseman death
of course what apocalypse also does here
is he pits all four the horsemen against
each other in a conflict and again for
apocalypse this is touching back on the
idea that the strong will are the ones
that should survive and the weak should
be the ones to perish and so what he
says here is that the person who is able
to defeat all of the other horsemen will
in turn be their leader and with angel
having haven't received prodigious
training at the hands of the other x-men
as well as a long side x-factor in
addition to a Charles Xavier is the one
who comes out on top and so Archangel is
the de facto leader of the four horsemen
group now from here we transition to
x-factor issues number 23 to 28 and what
we see over the course is apocalypse
actually making his move this is when we
see him taking the four horsemen and
pinning the four horsemen out in an
effort to assault the city of Manhattan
and over the course of this series we
see a litany of things taking place we
of course see the Caliban approaches
apocalypse and tells apocalypse that he
wants more power because of the fact
that the Marauders had wiped out the
Morlocks or a large portion of the
Morlocks he wanted to not only get
revenge against the Marauders but also
wanted to be in a position to where if
something like this were to happen again
he would be able to stop it he would be
able to to be more than a person who can
simply just track down mutants now what
apocalypse does here is he doesn't
actually make Caliban a
horsemen what he does is simply call
Caliban as hellhound meaning that he
puts caliban's ability to track down
mutants to his own use now what we see
over the course of issues number 23
through 28 or several things the first
thing we'll see is of course that uh the
the horsemen are battling X Factor and
the skies above Manhattan but we also
see that apocalypse basically wipes out
a huge portion of Manhattan when a ship
crashes into the city which leads to
almost countless deaths millions of
people being injured as well as multiple
fatalities and so over the course of
this conflict plague is encountered I
guess pestilence is encountered by a
powerpack who of course we're fighting
alongside X Factor in an attempt to to
keep the damage at a minimal but during
the conflict with a powerpack pestilence
is knocked off her horse and when she is
she's killed and so what this does is it
allows apocalypse to in turn make
Caliban the horseman pestilence now this
doesn't happen until the end of this run
until the end of issue number 28 but
what we also see is that with issue
number 25 arc angel believes that he's
killed Iceman and the way this happens
is that of course the x-men doing battle
with Archangel are also attempting to
get him to regain his bearings
attempting to get him to read who he is
as a person and to escape the
brainwashing of apocalypse arc angel
being so entrenched in this brainwashing
fails to understand what they're saying
but when Bobby Drake makes an ice statue
of himself of course uh Warren
Worthington attacks it and breaks it in
half and this sends him into a mentally
deranged state where he feels like he's
killed one of his closest friends and a
member of the x-men team and so what
archangel does is he immediately turns
against apocalypse he realizes that
apocalypse has turning to turn him into
a perversion of his former self now of
course archangel doesn't have the
ability to overcome apocalypse his power
just isn't that vast but what this does
is it allows Warren Worthington to leave
the confines of apocalypse and to in
turn make his own make his own way and
come to his understanding I guess regain
his bearings of who he is as a person
now this is a very important moment in
the the history of the horsemen and the
reason why is because with Archangel
being the horsemen death when he leaves
there
be another horseman death for quite some
time now from here we transition to the
Incredible Hulk - I issued number 455 -
457 and with these stories what we get
is that we pick up with the Incredible
Hulk with Bruce Banner after the events
of the onslaught saga so of course we
have the heroes reborn universe and
different things like that but for the
most part there are a lot of different
things taking place or a lot of
different things going on so we're not
necessarily going to get too far into
that but what we have here is a
situation whereby the Incredible Hulk is
haunted by both the ghost of his dead
father as well as the ability to draw
off the power of the heroes reborn
universe which is Marvel's way of
explaining how it is at the Incredible
Hulk has more enhanced abilities than he
previously did
but what apocalypse does here and what I
consider to be one of the more well
crafted stories is he gives us an event
on two fronts the first thing he does is
he sets the seeds for what will later
become the basis of the storyline called
the twelve a situation in which
apocalypse goes to gather a multitude of
various mutants for the purpose of
giving himself the ability to be on par
with the Celestials what apocalypse
tells us here in these issues of The
Incredible Hulk
is that the Celestials are returning and
because the Celestials are returning
they're going to expect I guess payments
from apocalypse but because apocalypse
doesn't isn't going to be able to
provide them with what it is that he
wants woody or what they want what he
wants to do is he wants to turn the
Incredible Hulk into his horseman war
and if the Incredible Hulk is as
powerful or more powerful than the
apocalypse and he will be able to aid
apocalypse and staving off the attempts
of the Celestials to most likely invoke
their wrath against apocalypse and so
what he does what apocalypse does is he
goes to the Incredible Hulk he
effectively kidnaps him in the middle of
a conflict when he's tearing up the the
Xavier Institute and what he what he
reveals I guess to the Incredible Hulk
is what apocalypse considers his
weakness apocalypse tells The Incredible
Hulk that the problem is he's very
easily manipulated that he's just not
very intelligent and because he's not
very intelligent his mind is is I guess
open to psychic probes but more so than
that that uh
better I guess Betty Ross is really the
the Achilles heel of his existence that
while Betty Ross has the capability if
injured to send the Incredible Hulk into
an enraged state that would be that
would make him a formidable threat to
any Argost to all but the most powerful
beings in the Marvel Universe Betty Ross
is also the one person that the
Incredible Hulk cares about the most and
so she is his weakness and so what he
tells The Incredible Hulk is that he can
remove that weakness he can put the
Incredible Hulk in a place to where no
one can take advantage of him and so the
Incredible Hulk decides to go through
with this but with the Incredible Hulk
it seems to us as the reader that he
might have some underlying motivation
here the motivation being escaping the
haunting element of his father within
his mind and so what what apocalypse
does is he hits the Incredible Hulk
against a group called the New World
Order now the New World Order is exactly
what it sounds like it's an organization
very similar to advanced idea mechanics
a group that wants to more or less take
over the world and so what the New World
Order does is in response to this they
send two people the first person they
send is the absorbing man and the second
person is the juggernaut you know what
the absorbing man of course we see that
almost immediately after he arrives he's
defeated by by the Incredible Hulk
when the Incredible Hulk catches their
attention by picking up a pyramid and
throwing it at him but what we see when
the juggernaut arrives here is that the
juggernaut is initially able to go
toe-to-toe with the Incredible Hulk that
he's able to physically match the
Incredible Hulk and in fact overpower
the Incredible Hulk but then after a
short time the Incredible Hulk is able
to stop the juggernaut in his tracks and
this is a very big moment in Marvel
Comics and the reason why is because up
until this point it was always believed
that juggernaut was unstoppable that
once the juggernaut started moving that
no one could stop him and so this showed
us just how far the Incredible Hulk
power went when the augmentations were
made at the hands of of apocalypse and
so over the course of these comics we
also see that Rick Jones that one of the
closest friends of the Incredible Hulk
is alongside absorbing man and ngns and
a couple other people as this conflict
is taking place but when the Incredible
Hulk and juggernaut arriving
and they begin fighting each other
within the city of Cairo Rick Jones
tries to stop them and in the process
the Incredible Hulk attacks Rick Jones
now was at this moment the Incredible
Hulk realizes what's going on here of
course the The Haunting figure of his
father returns despite the fact that the
shrapnel within his head had been
removed which had spurned a lot of these
things but what we also see is the
Incredible Hulk regaining his sanity
stripping away the armour from his body
that apocalypse had given him the
augmentations that apocalypse had given
him and then going about his own
business to try to figure out what it is
that he needs to do now from here we
transition to Wolverine to the events
that are prior to and during the 12 now
again the 12 was a circumstance whereby
apocalypse had gathered various mutants
12 mutants all of whom represented
different aspects of reality for the
most part think of it as a mutant
version of the the infinity gems and
what he wants to do is he wants to
channel their powers directly into the
living monolith and the living monolith
will in turn channel those energies
directly into apocalypse which will
imbue him with the ability to recreate
any facet of anything to in effect to
eliminate the Celestials entirely and to
recreate the world or the reality as he
sees fit and so over the course of these
comics we of course see that apocalypse
is defeated but during this time we pick
up with Wolverine now this is after the
events of fatal attractions and so at
this point we've already encountered
fair Wolverine and so on but Wolverine
does not have any adamantium in his body
and so what happens is Wolverine is
kidnapped and he has taken to a temple
and he is forced to engage in conflict
with Sabretooth now over the course of
the comic is revealed to us that
apocalypse had initiated this entire
circumstance whereby Wolverine is
fighting against Sabretooth and what
apocalypse wants to do is take one of
them to be his horsemen death but again
sticking with the most notable trend of
Apocalypse that the strong should
overtake the weak he pits the two of
them against each other and whichever
one wins will in turn become the
horseman death of course Wolverine
coming out on top is the one selected by
apocalypse to become his horseman but
over the course of the next several
issues issue number 146 issue number 147
we see that with Wolverine his
brainwashing is overcome by a
combination of the mental powers of
Psylocke and cerebro as well as Jubilee
and the other x-men who are trying to
rationale or I guess rationalize with
Wolverine eventually the brainwashing is
overcome entirely and Wolverine returns
back to the x-men but this is the common
trend that you see with the Horsemen of
apocalypse it's usually the horsemen war
or death but with the the the horsemen
of apocalypse either apocalypse goes to
them in a very vulnerable state or
apocalypse goes to them and simply
forces them to become a horseman but it
usually always turns out that the
horsemen betray Apocalypse Now for
apocalypse this isn't a very huge deal
because at any point apocalypse could
most likely eradicate any of the
horsemen he could wipe them out entirely
but again apocalypse uses this I guess
as a rationale to say that the strong
should overtake the weak and so for him
the horsemen that he's chosen are what
he's period what he perceives to be the
strongest members the strongest people
who are capable of holding their own in
any given situation but with the axis
event that's currently going on now we
see that apocalypse has returned that
the I guess kit apocalypse or Evan as we
had previously called him has now
returned to his former self to the
person that Deathlok had had perceived
him to most likely turn into and with
the return of apocalypse the question is
becoming will the four horsemen return
will we see the four horsemen come back
or will this axis version of apocalypse
be a different kind of apocalypse is he
really still interested in the mecha
nations and the motivations of only the
strong surviving or is this simply just
something that he's saying we don't
really know what's going on with his
character again we're only a couple
issues into his return and so we don't
really know what direction things are
going to take what happening said we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if
you did let me know and I will catch you
guys later
you